Arianna Huffington is no slacker when it comes to work...
...so it's almost surprising to hear the editor-in-chief...
...encourages a designated area to nap in the workplace.
I always knew that woman was a genius.
Huffington says people who are well-rested are actually more productive.
She even wrote a book called "The Sleep Revolution" about the importance of sleep.
Predicting in the next two years, nap areas will be as common as conference rooms.
At least three well-known companies agree and already have a place for snoozing:...
...Google, Zappos and Ben & Jerry's.
Although if I worked at B & J's, I'd be eating so much ice cream during the day,...
...I wouldn't have time for sleep.
Arianna's concept stems from the idea people are perfectly capable of functioning...
...on just four, five hours of shut-eye.
She disagrees and wrote the book to examine the theory...
...to regain control over our out-of-kilter lives.
Napping at work would be so cool!